I'm here with Dr. Bill Dally, who is Chief Scientist and Senior Vice president of Research NVIDIA.
Welcome, Bill.
Well, thanks John. It's a pleasure to be here.
I'm glad to have an opportunity to chat with you about important trends in computing.
Super, tell us about your job in NVIDIA. What do you do?
I really have two jobs.
As Chief Scientist, I get to sort of look into a lot of neat technologies that we're developing
and try to set technical directions in certain strategic areas work with key customers
and partners on technology initiatives.
And then as Senior Vice President of Research, I build and lead NVIDIA Research,
which is a world class research lab doing research in a lot of interesting areas from graphics to parallel computing
to circuits and architecture programming systems relevant to the future of NVIDIA.